how are you guys doing today we're
awesome man how are you I just want to
say one thing
brother you got to roll with him in the
good times and the bad we're at 20 year
run we'll be back don't give up hope
really funny you say this because every
Michelle you don't know this but every
time Mark and I talk uh I start every
interview off talking about Boston
Sports because we're both from Boston oh
wow okay and I and I do have an
individual question about Boston sports
for Mark and here we go well I did I did
find myself rooting for them to lose to
get the good draft pick and of course as
soon as I rooted for them to lose they
won yeah we're on the exact same page so
here's here's my question um do you
think that bill bellich who you know I
love he won all these Super Bowls for us
like what is the threshold for us with
Bill bellich coaching for the Patriots
is there a limit to like an a certain
amount of losing Seasons before we
really have to say it might be time for
you to go or because of how many Super
Bowls he won he has like cart blanch
well I think cart blanch for a while I
think you know it's very premature you
know having you know an unprecedented
20-some year run uh dominating the
entire league not only the division but
so I I think it's very unfair right now
the scrutiny that he's getting and you
know he's the greatest coach of all time
so let him do his thing if he wants to
win you know three games in the season
or four or five you know he's there's a
method to the madness and who are we to
question what his approach is that's
what I was trying to explain to my wife
as we were watching the game and they
were
winning I was like I I would like to see
them kind of lose and and you know uh
dump the season to get a good draft pick
but he's got a plan in mind and so let
him do his thing he certainly earned it
uh and and I've gotten so much joy from
them winning that I'm okay with with
them not being that great I mean
everybody else is loving to talk
about the Patriots excuse my language
but you know they they've been down for
a long time getting stepped on by the
Patriots so let them enjoy their fun I
agree with you I think that he has
brought so much joy to my life that
whatever he wants to do I'm sort of on
board ah he's the best there's a method
to the
madness